all right who wants to talk about
servers are servers exciting no no no I
don't believe that for a second they're
boring although we do have a really hot
data center so
all right it's all downhill from here
all right so uh at comma we train models
machine learning models for open Pilots
uh and we always want to train bigger
models faster iterate faster
and so we need lots of servers to do
that
this is a picture of our prior office we
moved to a new office recently and this
is what we used to have for servers for
training models and you can't really see
the servers because this is in a really
dirty garage and
um the only way to really filter the air
with a giant garage door and all kinds
of stuff going on in there was to put
filter media right on the front of the
servers to try to keep the dirt from
going into the servers
so you can see here
this is a four car garage there's room
for four cars and the servers take up
less than one car spot so really not a
lot of space here for our servers
um
this is about 5.68 petaflops of B float
16 performance we measure everything in
B float 16 because that's what our
models are and so that's all we really
care about
um this whole room or this slice of the
garage we spent about 500 000 on the
servers getting power in here in the
ventilation and everything
so in the old office we ran out of power
we couldn't handle the amount of heat we
were generating
this the whole building only had about
200 amps of power that tiny panel in the
picture on the right there is all the
power for the whole building
the ventilation was the best we could do
we had to Skylight up in the top and we
had an intake and exhaust fan that were
up in the ceiling you can see the
skylight on the left there I kind of
propped it open because I needed more
airflow because the skylight's pretty
restrictive and for a good reason we
don't want rain coming down in on our
servers but when it was really hot I
would maybe try to prop it openings a
little more get a little more airflow
so it wasn't great we ran out of power
we didn't have enough airflow we wanted
to train models faster we wanted to buy
more servers we didn't have the power
more we wanted to buy more servers more
servers means more power more power
means more heat so we moved to a new
office
uh a big criteria for the new office was
way more power we found a place with 8X
the power of our previous office and for
the first time the servers are not in a
garage
they have a room
so
uh this is the room that we chose uh it
started out empty it was not obviously
it wasn't for servers
the first thing we did was we ran 800
amps of power into the room this was
pretty expensive we spent for all the
electrical work in the room we ended up
spending about 125 thousand dollars
the power was kind of on the wrong
corner of the building for the servers
so it was quite a ways we had to run the
power and stuff but thank goodness we
had a place with lots of power so now we
can run lots more servers
so in this room we added a couple short
walls these walls are basically to help
with hot aisle containing the hot aisle
some partial walls the racks obviously
go in between those walls there we have
these 42u racks that we use
we knocked out some windows so I guess I
didn't really explain it but just like
in our last data center we only had fans
it was a garage no air conditioning
we're in San Diego and we can
potentially save a ton of money not
using air conditioning so what we do is
we we just use fans you can see the
windows boarded up here
and then we installed some really big
fans
uh these are
oh thanks yeah I guess the fans are more
exciting than the servers huh the uh the
fans are three horsepower each fan does
about 28 000 CFM uh the room's pretty
small we can exchange all the air in the
room in less than 10 seconds so these
are quite powerful
then inside the room this is one of
those hot aisle containment walls we
also have some fans that recirculate air
so we can basically take the hot air and
bring it back to the cold aisle when we
need to
um because sometimes we need to raise
the temperature on the cold aisle I set
our data center is hot we run a high
temperature Data Center and I'll get
into that a little bit more uh so
sometimes it's not hot enough in our
data center and we make it hotter
and then the last thing was we just use
a strip curtain anti-static strip
curtain to kind of seal off from the uh
from the front side from the ceiling to
the top of the server or to the floor if
uh if there's no servers in the racks
and certain in certain racks
um
then the last thing is
um we want to make sure that the air
temperature from the ceiling all the way
to the floor is a very similar
temperature I'll get into more the
humidity and why but basically we need
an even temperature so we have even
humidity all the way from the floor to
the ceiling so these are called
de-stratification fans they just suck
air in from the ceiling and they push it
back down to the floor to even out the
temperature
so this is what the room looks like
after we built that all out there's two
intake fans on the ends that bring in
air from the outside there goes through
the servers through the racks and then
there's two big fans that shoot the heat
out the back and then on the sides
there's two recirculation fans and you
can see those recirculation fans are
kind of pointed at the intake fans or
where the intake fans blow in and I
thought I was gonna have to do something
way more complicated it turns out you
just point fans at each other and the
air mixes amazingly well so
foreign
so in our data center our intake
temperature goes up to 43c Why well we
always want to keep the cold aisle at
the outside temperature or lower and in
San Diego it can get up to it can get up
around 110 degrees sometimes uh rarely
and so that's kind of the max the max
temperature that we designed everything
for on the intake side exhaust side we
try to keep it we try to keep it below
like 55c it generally stays around like
53 at the most so
this is a picture of we buy a lot of
used servers and it's kind of funny to
see uh we have like temperature history
in The BMC of the servers so you can see
like oh well what What did the what was
this server what was the temperature
this server was like in its previous
life before we bought it and you can see
you know it runs around 21c in some you
know beautiful climate controlled
Data Center and then uh we have a peak
temperature of 42 there once it starts
running in our data center so
we abuse them
you can find data on how much on how
much power data centers often use on
Cooling and it's crazy like I don't know
if most people realize this but it's not
super uncommon for a data center to
spend more power on the climate control
basically on air conditioning then they
give power to the servers
so that's not great like
power's expensive especially in
California we want to use as little
power as possible for the for the
climate control and as much as possible
for the uh
um for the servers
so we do we do way better we if all of
our fans are running full power we're
using eight kilowatts and that's less
than four percent of all the power that
our data center uses and we don't always
use for uh that that four percent or
that eight kilowatts of power in our old
office we had fans that were just on or
off they were either full speed or or
they were zero uh and that made the
climate control a lot more difficult to
to reach a desired temperature and stay
stable and so forth so now we have
variable speed control fans
um this picture on the right here is a
vfd we just have you know they're just
three-phase Motors and you can use a vfd
to basically scale the the voltage and
the frequency up
um and then we can run the fan at any
speed based on on that
there's there's one other big benefit to
this which is if you have big fans when
you turn them on they draw like huge
power initially so so each of these fans
if you just like flip a switch and they
suddenly get power
for a period of time they're going to
draw 80 amps each
and so
when they're running once they get up
and spinning full speed uh
then they only use like five amps or
less so the problem is is if you don't
have something like a vfd controlling
your fans then what happens is you have
to leave all this overhead power that
you can't really give to your servers
because well what if the fans need to
turn on so these vfds were really
important in maximizing the amount of
power that was available to the servers
so that we didn't have to leave all this
all this power overhead available just
to turn on the fans
so these vfds basically limit you can
configure how they work but we basically
limit them to the max power that the fan
uses at full speed so if our fans are
using 5 amps when they're running full
speed we don't let it draw more than 5
amps as it ramps up to uh as it gets
started and ramps up speed
for the climate control
we wrote software that we wrote custom
software that does the climate control
we have these temperature sensors this
is a picture of one of the one of the
temperature sensors here that we have
throughout the room basically the inputs
to the climate control system is the
temperature and the humidity
um
so what we want to do is we want to
maintain a humidity of 30 to 40 percent
inside the room we actually don't
directly it's kind of unintuitive but we
don't try to control the temperature in
the room we try to control the humidity
uh and since we're in San Diego we don't
have any problems where like it's both
high temperature and high humidity so
anytime it's really hot it's not humid
outside so uh since that's the case this
I guess this works for us it obviously
wouldn't work for everyone and so uh
yeah so we're just always trying to
achieve a 30 to 40 percent humidity and
the reason that we're so focused on
humidity is because we've had a lot of
problems in our garage data centers with
humidity because when the humidity gets
really high especially if it's dirty
that dust holds some moisture and
moisture on metal is going to cause
corrosion so we need to keep the
humidity below the point where corrosion
will happen and so that's why we we
manage the humidity and try to keep it
down below that 40 percent line for sure
so the way our we have a pretty darn
simple climate control algorithm
basically it uh it takes the input of
the temperature sensors in the room to
get the humidity of the room and the
temperature of the room currently uh to
figure out like the relative humidity
then
um we know we want to Target this 30 to
40 percent we come up with a temperature
that will achieve that 30 to 40 percent
and then we vary the speeds of the fans
to using a PID controller until we reach
that that Target temperature
um
so yeah
it's pretty basic basically if the
relative humidity is too high we need to
make it hotter because as you raise the
temperature the relative humidity of the
air will come down and if it's too cold
or I'm sorry if it's too cold the
relative humidity will be too high we
need to raise the temperature and
um
so we we recirculate the air in that
case and then you have the uh
if the relative humidity is too high
then I'm sorry the relative humidity is
too low well generally the outside air
has higher humidity than what's in the
room so we're exchanging the outside air
and bringing that in and then obviously
we have like the mixing going on so that
we can we can basically take the high
humidity air that's coming in shoot hot
air at it from the back side of the
servers and get our desired relative
humidity on the cola on the cold aisle
side of the servers
so this is it this is what it all looks
like now uh
we now have approximately
55.88 petaflops of B float 16
performance so we basically 10xed our
our
with all these fancy new servers we
bought well a lot of them are used I
shouldn't say that nudos
we now have about 10x the uh the
throughput
and we ended up spending about uh 1.5
million dollars so I mentioned I think
that the all the electrical stuff cost
us like 125 000 all the ventilation
stuff cost us like another seventy five
thousand dollars some of the equipment
that I'm counting here uh is like money
we already spent so like those those
that's included in this total and then
we bought you know additional servers up
to this up to this number here basically
um so
so how does that compare to other super
computers so all we care since all we
care about is B float 16 performance
it's it's not exactly straightforward to
compare it but we can come up with
something relatively meaningful uh this
top 500 list maybe you've heard of it
before it's like the top 500 super
computers in the world it's not like a
comprehensive list you submit to be on
it if you want to uh we don't and part
of the reason why is because well this
is this is uh fp64 performance which
like who uses that but if you look at
this list and you find
um I look through this list and I found
some systems with modern gpus and uh
if you find systems around like four
petaflops of fp64 with modern gpus they
have around they have around 60
petaflops of B float 16 performance and
those are around like the 175 certainly
above the 200 Mark so in terms of B
float 16 performance we're somewhere
comparable to like 175 to 200 on this
very narrow axis at least and um
uh
just for B float 16 performance and if
they have modern gpus some of these are
like all CPU systems and just you know
not really comparable at all
so the high level specs we use about 205
kilowatts of power when all the servers
are running uh Full Tilt we have 580
5088 CPU cores which is actually a very
small number uh we have 640 gpus some of
the gpus we've got all the hardware some
of the gpus are still being installed
but that's what we have in the room just
not quite some of them aren't in the
servers yet
and 2.1 petabytes of solid-state storage
so we have kind of two classes of
servers in this system we have servers
that train the models and then we have
what we call rollout servers that feed
the trainers so the trainers
they each have eight gpus
um
that's 2.64 petaflops of v-float 16
performance combined for all eight of
those they have a hundred gigabit
Ethernet and 400 gigabit infiniband so
the the 100 gigabit Ethernet is
basically feeding data into the servers
and the infiniband that's to sync across
the servers so one of the things that we
do now that we didn't really do before
is we often train models on multiple
like train the same model on multiple
servers at the same time so we have this
massive bandwidth to sync data between
the gpus on our trainer servers
um
so yeah we spend about 25 000 on each of
these servers and for the trainers we
generally buy new hardware
um
to get us the you can actually generally
get the most dollars per flop
um buying some newer stuff
so the rollout servers they are these
two EU servers that look like this they
we we shove two gpus in them
um
for running models they have 238
teraflops of B float 16 performance then
we have another two gpus for decoding
frames I'll talk about that more a
little bit later here
they have 20 gigabits of ethernet uh we
have 100 of these so they don't need
they don't need massive uh ethernet
connectivity and then some of them are
part of our distributed file system that
stores all our driving data
um if they do they have this 40
terabytes of storage currently you can
kind of see in the picture here up high
they have some disk drives in them down
low they don't so like those top ones
there are are uh they're we we have dual
purpose rollout servers they're both
part of our distributed file system and
also for rollout
so the 2500 that we spend per server on
these servers doesn't include the
storage
um that's just everything else that's in
there we build these so cheap because we
uh we buy all this I think everything in
these servers is used except for the
disk drives I guess
um which isn't in that 2500 anyway
so that distributed file system that I
was talking about it has all of our
driving data that we use for training
the models
um
So currently I looked and we have 3.84
million segments what we call a segment
is a one minute clip of driving it has
both some video files and a log file for
each segment and we store it in the key
Value Store our distributed file system
is this key value store called mini key
value I talked about it in great detail
in my talk two years ago if you're
interested in how that works but yeah
it's basically a key value store that we
wrote that's super simple we looked at
all the other options and they're like
crazy complex and we just needed
something super super simple it's less
than a thousand lines of code
that driving data uh
it's from 11 000 unique devices so we've
got a lot of we've got a pretty good
amount of data diversity now we
generally have I don't think we've ever
been limited by data diversity up to
this point at least
um so 11 000 devices is basically like
eleven thousand Vehicles 191 platforms
or or types of vehicles uh
cover those 11 000 devices and uh 66
countries there's a lot of there's a lot
of uh data from a lot of different
countries when we build our training
lists we kind of pick a slice of this
data like the best slice because we
often do things like say oh well most of
our day is from the us but we also want
data from other countries and so forth
we want to keep things like balance so
um so yeah we kind of slice and dice it
and uh take a subset of all this data to
build our training lists for training
models for openpilot
so the first step or kind of the the
start of the data flow through the whole
training process is reading those video
files uh those video files are you know
recorded on their you know real people
driving their uh driving their commas
their common devices
um the common devices encode that video
in h.265 and one of the first things we
need to do is decode those frames
um and so part of the reason that our
um our rollout servers have both two
gpus for running models and two gpus
just to get more decoders is because we
need to decode we need to do so much
video decoding of these h.265 files so
that whole that whole rollout system
that we have can decode 300 000 frames
per second and then so that's mainly the
uh the two gpus two gpus with used for
decoding then those frames feed into the
models that are for example our
simulator
and those uh those gpus in the rollout
servers they can output 200 000 FPS once
we get all the gpus up in all those
servers
the models that we train for open pilot
that actually output the plan for open
pilot
um it's a kind of a two-step we train
two models basically is what I'm trying
to say for that uh the the input to
those models is like the road camera the
frames the first model the vision model
takes in those frames and outputs a
feature vector
so that's one model we train that Vision
model then that feature Vector is input
into the policy model and the policy
model
um takes in the feature vector and
outputs the plan that openpilot executes
so just to give you an idea of what the
size of these models are the vision
model which takes in frames outputs
features it's two efficient Nets at
21.47 million parameters and to give you
an idea of the speed up we achieved by
moving from the old office to the new
office
basically we went from 12 hours in the
old office to four hours in the new
office so
quite an improvement uh really increased
our Ripple time which is great so that
was the first Model the second one the
policy model that we have to train
that one is an MLP with 5.3 million
parameters used to take us 21 hours to
train now it only takes us seven so now
we're like 11 hours now to train the
models that we need to train to ship to
ship open pilot so that's pretty cool
so uh we did a pretty good job 1.5
million is pretty cheap for everything
we built
the supercomputer that was like the
closest in that top 500 list that gave
similar performance
um that's like a minimum of 3.75 million
dollar computer for sure and that
doesn't include like the building or you
know like all the the power and
ventilation and so forth that we that I
included in you know we spent on ours so
we did pretty good in terms of dollars
per flops but we can do a lot better and
uh you know maybe in two years my next
talk is going to be talking about the
tiny boxes in our data center we'll see
[Music]
[Applause]
any questions
what's up
yeah so the question was uh are we like
unique in running a high temperature
Data Center and he mentioned that like
in Iceland they like do stuff uh
different you know kind of different
steps I've definitely heard of like high
temperature Data Centers before I don't
know like what my background is not data
centers I was a web device I was a web
slash application developer before I
worked at comma who migrated a big
company into the cloud uh worked on
cloud infrastructure at comma and said
wow this is expensive and stupid we
should buy more servers and that's how I
kind of fell into this so
um so I don't have like industry
experience on this but I've definitely
read about other high temperature data
centers what temperature that is I guess
I'm not really sure and I'm sure they do
it for dollar reasons
um but uh yeah it definitely works I
mean I don't know why baby I don't know
why I don't know why people baby their
servers so much I guess the like our
reliability in terms of uh temperature I
don't think we've had anything dude
failed due to temperature in any if
anything all our failures were due to
corrosion and the only way we get
corrosion is if it's too cold in our
data center so
uh so yeah
uh go ahead and yeah you're so awesome
[Laughter]
thank you
hello I have a question regarding word
usage I noticed that you mentioned the
word data center quite often and I was
watching the geohots podcast with Lex
Friedman a few weeks ago a few days ago
and I noticed that he was reluctant on
using the word data usage because
you guys don't have air conditioning you
guys have fans and yeah so he said it's
not a data center because you're using
fans so my question is what are your
thoughts on this but also second case
did you do any cost analysis on fan
usage because that you use really big
fans versus Air Conditioning ah yeah so
I mean I did some cost analysis to you
know know like I knew what it was going
to cost to buy air conditioning units
that we're going to do you know 200 what
was it 205 kilowatt cooling 200 kilo 205
kilowatts of power consumption you know
because that that all turns into heat
and that's like crazy expensive uh now
we bought big fans
um I found like some models that said
like if your temperature difference is
this many see you need this many CFM you
know exchanged to uh you know bring the
temperature down this much and so forth
so I kind of ran some rough numbers
bought fans considerably bigger than
that I think uh and then felt safe that
it was going to work and uh yeah
is that your only server room or what do
you have for backup solution in case
like there's no power in San Diego for
like three days yeah so I didn't really
talk about our production facing
infrastructure this is all for research
so anything production facing is in uh
is in a cloud provider we use Azure for
uh for our customer facing
infrastructure this stuff it'd be really
annoying if this stuff went down but uh
we're fine with you know some
reliability issues and basically we
exchange uh you know part of the reason
that we can do this so cheap compared to
the cloud one of the reasons we don't
run this in the cloud and we can do it
so much cheaper is because we're not
striving for some crazy number of nines
uptime I mean we are but we'll accept
some down time to save massive massive
amounts of money
um and but we can you know like I don't
know how much downtime we've had I guess
I haven't really calculated it which
obviously means it hasn't been a problem
so
um
so yeah I guess uh
yeah we don't run it in the cloud
because it's too expensive compared to
what we've done uh and we know that uh
we know that like our return on
investment is you know if you include
like the cost of the room and everything
uh just for the servers it's like six
months or something like that that we
that we are better off so with the room
it's longer but still it's uh we know
it's way cheaper than the other
alternatives
all right
so um I have a question regarding the
vision model but what do you use to
supervise this efficient night I don't
know the answer to that
uh but the research people would you
should find your scene or someone or
Harold he's speaking next okay yes you
should ask that question to the next
person
I have a question regarding the gpus
that you use it seems the server is very
cheap yeah yeah so what's the what's the
GPU used for the training and what's for
the inference yeah so for training the
cheapest dollars per flop
whatever that is that's what we buy for
training we need the most dollars per
flop
s you know what you tell me because if
you find something better I would love
to know and I want to buy them
and then so that and then you asked also
for the for the rollout servers so that
we actually need the highest uh memory
bandwidth per flop uh because uh we run
much bigger models
um and so the models don't fit in cash
and when the models don't fit in cash
you end up memory bandwidth limited
because you're running batch size one on
your rollout so for those it's the
cheapest memory bandwidth per flop yeah
I also have another question regarding
the training of the of the model it
seems like there are two models the
perception model first and then there's
a policy model yes and I thought it's
it's end-to-end training should be so
how how's that how do you train these
models separately you should shouldn't
you do this uh end to end great question
for you seeing the next person
save that one
we got a few more questions
uh so you mentioned it takes uh four
hours of the transaction model uh do I
mean the whole training process or just
the epoch of the model
what was the first part uh you mentioned
it takes four hours to train the vision
model yeah seven hours to change your
MLP model so it doesn't mean does it
mean the whole training process or just
the one ipok
oh the whole yeah the whole training
process oh the whole Chinese yeah yeah
that's cool yep
those models are fully trained in in
that many hours
and ready like potential candidates to
ship well I guess they have to be merged
and tested and all that stuff but
hey uh first quick uh uh a quick comment
on the hot data center thing why don't
more people do that I did actually ask
this question by happenstance some of my
old tech leads and he said will it be
too hot for the people in the data
center yeah that was his answer it is
hot in there yeah it's pretty yeah yeah
sometimes it's cold in the rest of the
office though it's actually it can be
refreshing when you walk in there
uh
I mean yeah I'm not really sure
I think a lot of I think it's becoming
way more common I I swear I've read
about some Microsoft data centers that
are all fans and like if you look up
like fan walls you'll find data centers
that have like a giant fan wall
um I feel like that's like kind of Gone
by the wayside now and that was like a
multi-year ago thing now and they're
doing something else but it definitely I
don't know I might even be like a
generation behind there's like better
stuff now probably
wow well I do have an actual question
for you which is yes
um that was very interesting I will look
up a fan wall
um I want one but
um better than a plant wall
what's uh has anybody that you know of
achieved a lower all-in cost per
petaflop for training and then you guys
again I don't really have any experience
in like uh industry
infrastructure like server Data Center
building stuff so I really don't know I
think a lot of this information is just
not public either
I promise you the answers no okay
okay so we're 2x under anything else
George has seen uh I guess we did a good
job I just did the best I could do uh
and I always tell people I don't really
know what I'm doing so I guess you know
why you know why it's so good it's
because this is our third data center
right so we iterated
yeah we think this one is good but two
more and it'll we'll be saying this one
was horrible I'm sure
going back to temperature so you said 50
something degrees Celsius was about as
hot as it gets do you have any idea like
what you're seeing on the actual die I
imagine it's some number oh uh I mean
the gpus they throttle it somewhere
around 88c on the gpus something like
that
um
I'm sure the exhaust gets above 60 but
then it expands out into the room
so
yeah I'm not I'm trying to think of any
other temperatures I know yeah that's
that's the best I can guess
we got time for one more question
anyone there's someone up here oh thanks
Greg
so thanks for the talk
um how long does it take to put up a
supercomputer do you have to do it in
stages or just
how long does it take to what the super
computer
no boot
oh they start you power everything off
and then turn back on how long does it
put most of the I mean most of the
servers Boot and are ready to run things
in I think under three minutes we're
actually talking about like saving even
more on Power by shutting off like 40 of
them and then like turning them on uh
when they're needed so individual
servers they take like three minutes or
so and yeah they all start in parallel
so it should be
on the order of minutes single digit
minutes
one more question
real quick percent wise like let's say
on a 30C day what percentage were you
running your uh your your fans at and do
you run the exhaust and then take fans
at different speeds uh so sometimes we
run the exhaust fans and we don't run
the intake fans and so part of that is
because
um
you saw like there's like baffles on the
fans and they're just uh they're just
like mechanical baffles so we need to
run the fans fast enough that the
baffles open up so there's kind of a
minimum fan speed that we need to run
the fans at
so we don't run them all at the same
speed we kind of support using them in a
staged manner to uh to get like a lower
airflow than if they're all running at
low speed so for example like sometimes
we run the exhaust fans and we don't run
the intake fans and say they're running
at like 30 percent uh that's that's
somewhat less airflow than if we run the
the exhaust fans and the intake fans at
um at that 30 so uh so yeah we kind of
do that but generally that we're doing
that because the humidity is getting too
high and then we also have the
recirculation going on that's helping
raise it at the same time basically and
then real quick I know you all said you
I know years prior you had a data sales
thing like for like 200 000 a month did
anybody actually buy it I'm not aware of
anyone no
as far as I know no one's ever taken us
up on that
we do sell a lot of meetings though
all right thank you so much Greg yeah
yeah thanks a lot
[Applause]